♪ ♪
>> Greg: SO, LET’S REVIEW THE
MEDIA’S REACTION OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
>> THE SHEER VOLUME OF THINGS
ARE NOT TRUE OF WHAT HAS BEEN
SAID BY THE PRESIDENT AND SOME
OF HIS AIDES.
IT DOES NOT INSPIRED
CREDIBILITY.
>> IT HAS LEFT AS VULNERABLE
PEERS BECAUSE I FOUND MOST OF
WHAT HE SAID A LITTLE INCOHERENT
INCOHERENT.
THAT JUST TELLS YOU HOW LITTLE
HE ACTUALLY KNOWS ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH.
HE JUST REVEALED HOW IGNORANT HE
IS ABOUT THE SITUATION.
>> Greg: AND THEN THERE’S
CNN’S BALL OF HYSTERIA.
SINCE THE DAWN OF THE TRUMP ERA,
COUNTLESS EXPERTS HAVE WARNED
THAT THE PRESIDENT’S LACK OF
CREDIBILITY WOULD IMPERIL THE
COUNTRY IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY.
THAT ONE TWEET DEFINES THE
MEDIA’S DARK DESIRES FOR
SOMETHING BAD TO HAPPEN SO THAT
ALL OF THEIR PREVIOUS TRUMP
HATRED IS VALIDATED.
THE FEARS MAY BE COMING TRUE,
BRIAN RETWEETS.
EVERY STORY THAT COLLAPSES
HINGES ON MAY.
TRUMP MAY RESIGN.
TRUMP MAY NOT LEAVE OFFICE.
IT’S A WORD THAT PROVIDES COVER
FOR THE PRESS’ DELUSIONAL DREAM.
TODAY, THAT DREAM IS A DISEASE.
THIS TIME, PEOPLE WILL SURELY
DIE, BUT IT WILL BE TRUMP’S
FAULT.
AND THEN FINALLY, I WILL BE
RIGHT AND JEFF WILL GIVE ME A
LOLLIPOP.
MEANWHILE, GAIL COLLINS FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SAYS,
"LET’S CALL THE DISEASE "THE
TRUMP VIRUS."
ONLY A TRULY MINDLESS PAPER
WOULD STILL RUN HER LAUGHABLE
DRIBBLE.
THEY WOULD RATHER POLITICIZE
THAN HELP.
AS THEY CLAIM TO CHAMPION
CREDIBILITY, THEIR OWN
CREDIBILITY AS A JOKE.
CNN, "THE TIMES" CAN’T BE
TRUSTED ON ANY TOPIC, BECAUSE
THEIR DERANGED FILTER SPITS OUT
THE SAME ANSWER.
I WOULD CALL IT A PLAGUE,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS GAIL COLIN’S
DISEASE.
NOBODY KNOWS ANYTHING, DANA.
>> Dana: NOPE.
>> Greg: SO, LET’S POLITICIZE
IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: ONE THING I DID
ADMIRE, THE CONGRESSMAN FROM
CALIFORNIA, WHO IS THE POSTER OF
THE BERNIE SANDERS CAMPAIGN, HE
HAS REFUSED TO DO THAT EVEN
THOUGH BERNIE SANDERS OBVIOUSLY
WOULD LOVE TO TAKE ON
DONALD TRUMP IN THE ELECTION.
THE CORRECT ANSWER IS, HUMANITY
IS IN A RACE AGAINST THE
BIOLOGICAL CHANGES.
MOTHER NATURE IS LIKE, OH, YOU
KNOW WHAT?
I’M GOING TO TWEAK THIS LITTLE
VIRUS.
THOSE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN PUBLIC
HEALTH, THANK GOODNESS FOR THEM.
THEY SPEND 24/7 RACING AGAINST
THIS VIRUS.
IF YOU LOOK BACK AT HISTORY,
WE’VE KNOWN THAT THIS WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
THAT’S WHY YOU HAVE PUBLIC
HEALTH.
THAT’S WHY YOU HAVE DOCTORS WHO
ARE DEDICATED TO DEALING WITH
THE FLU AND THE CORONAVIRUS LIKE
THIS.
I THOUGHT THE REPORTERS IN THE
BRIEFING ROOM WERE ACTUALLY
REALLY RESPECTFUL, RESPONSIBLE,
ASKED GOOD QUESTIONS.
IT’S WHEN YOU GET INTO THE
COMMENTARY SIDE OF THINGS THAT
THINGS GET OFF THE RAIL.
SPEAK TO YOU, EMILY, ONE OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE MONTAGE,
EZEKIEL, WAS BASHING TRUMP,
BECAUSE HE WAS SURPRISED BY HOW
MANY PEOPLE DIED FROM THE FLU
EVERY YEAR.
EVERYBODY IS SURPRISED BY HOW
MANY PEOPLE DIE FROM THE FLU
COME BECAUSE EVERYONE IS SO USED
TO IT.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT TRUMP IS
SOME KIND OF IDIOT THAT LACKS
CREDIBILITY?
>> Emily: NOT TO ME.
THE PRESIDENT IS --
IF HE DOES -- GO IF HE DOESN’T.
EVERYONE IN THE COMMENTARY IS
GOING TO HAVE THAT RIDICULOUS
REACTION.
IN THINGS THAT ACTUALLY MATTER,
WHICH IS PUBLIC HEALTH BEING A
THREAT OF AN ACTUAL FATALITY,
EXASPERATION LEADS TO ZERO
TOLERANCE.
WHEN THE RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA
AND EVERYTHING IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS THAT WE’VE BEEN HEARING.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
YES, EVERYTHING IS HIS FAULT.
BUT WHEN IT’S SOMETHING LIKE
THIS WERE ACTUALLY, THE PUBLIC
NEEDS TRUE RELIANT INFORMATION,
NO ONE IS GOING TO WATCH THAT.
BY THE WAY, WHEN I WENT TO
WALGREENS EARLIER, IT WAS ALL
GONE FROM THE SHELF.
EVERYTHING, INCLUDING
TEMPERATURE TAKERS, WATER THOSE
CALLED?
>> Greg: THERMOMETERS?
>> Emily: THERMOMETERS.
IT’S MORE DEADLY THAN COVID-19.
IT WAS REDUCED TO 30-15% SIMPLE
BY HAND WASHING.
THERE ARE LITTLE THINGS LIKE
THAT OR AS USUAL, WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE PUTTING THEIR OWN HATRED
OF THE PRESIDENT OVER
DISSEMINATING SIMPLE FACTS.
>> Greg: YET, IN MASH WHEN
THEY WOULD JUST SIT THERE FOR
LIKE 10 MINUTES.
WHAT BOTHERS ME, CDC, IS THAT
SOMEONE LIKE GAIL COLLINS HAS NO
INTEREST.
WHEN PEOPLE COME HERE ON
"THE FIVE," AND WE ACTUALLY
OFFER SOLUTIONS AND WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE ON THE OTHER
SIDE, THE TRUMP HATERS, THEY
DON’T HAVE SOLUTIONS.
THEY JUST WANT TO POLITICIZE.
WE ACTUALLY SIT HERE AND TALK
ABOUT STUFF LIKE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS AND HYGIENE AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
I THINK WE’RE THE GOOD PEOPLE IN
THIS AND THEY ARE EVIL.
>> Juan: WELL, I THINK WE ARE
THE GOOD PEOPLE.
[LAUGHTER]
I DO WORRY WHEN YOU DON’T SAY,
HEY, WAIT A SECOND.
THERE IS REAL NEWS THERE WHEN
YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT CONTRADICT
THE WOMAN AT THE CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL.
SHE SAYS, IT’S NOT A MATTER OF
IF BUT WHEN.
THE PRESIDENT COMES BACK AND
SAYS, VERY LOW PROBABILITY.
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW THERE ARE
MANY MORE.
THEN, I THINK, THERE’S A REAL
ARGUMENT HERE.
I WOULD SAY THE PRESIDENT IN
TERMS OF HIS OWN ARGUMENT, HAS
MADE A VERY POLITICAL COME
BECAUSE HE COMES AT IT WITH
CALM DOWN, I’M GOING TO REASSURE
YOU.
NO REASON FOR ANY WORRY.
I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THE PRESIDENT ACTING IN
THAT WAY, BECAUSE I THINK THAT’S
PRESIDENTIAL.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND, I WANT TO
HEAR THE FACTS.
THE OTHER PART OF IT IS I SAY,
THIS PRESIDENT DOES HAVE A
CREDIBILITY ISSUE.
HE’S THE GUY WHO SAID, OH, THE
INAUGURATION AND ATTENDANCE SO
GREAT.
>> Greg: BIGGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD AND IT’S HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE.
I WOULD SAY THAT BOTH THINGS,
WHATEVER THE CDC SAID ARE
DIRECTIONAL AND TRUE.
THEY CAN BOTH BE TRUE.
>> Jesse: BUT I THINK THE
MEDIA HAS THE WORST CROP
DOLOMITE CREDIBILITY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TRUST THE
PRESIDENT MORE THAN THEY TRUST
THE MEDIA.
IT’S INEVITABLE THAT IT’S GOING
TO GET LARGER.
THE PRESIDENT SAID NOTHING IS
INEVITABLE.
IF YOU GET LARGER.
IT COULD GET SMALLER.
WE JUST DON’T KNOW.
THE GUY IS A GERM OF FALL.
HE IS TOUGH ON CHINA.
HE IS THE PERFECT PRESIDENT TO
TAKE ON THIS VIRUS.
YET, HE WAS CALLED A RACIST FOR
DOING IT.
NOW, THE CONTAINMENT STRATEGY SO
FAR IS WORKING.
NOT ONE SINGLE AMERICAN HAS DIED
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND ACCORDING TO JOHN HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY, AMERICA IS THE BEST
PREPARED COUNTRY IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD FOR THIS.
DOCKERS AND ADMINISTRATORS HAVE
BEEN MOBILIZED.
I’M VERY HAPPY WITH THE FACT
THAT A NEW YEAR, WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A VACCINE.
IN A COUPLE MONTHS, WE WILL HAVE
A THERAPEUTIC DRUG.
I THINK WE ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES.
WE ARE THE ONES WHO HAVE TO WASH
HER HANDS.
WE ARE THE ONES WHO HAVE TOOK
OFF LIKE THIS AND NOT GO TO
CHINA.
MAKE PREPARATIONS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN ONLY
DO SO MUCH AND IT’S THE
HOSPITALS AND THE ADMINISTRATORS
AND THE NURSES AND LOCALITIES,
NOT WASHINGTON, D.C.
THEY ARE THE ONES WERE GOING TO
HAVE TO HANDLE THIS.
SO FAR, THEY ARE DOING A REALLY,
REALLY GOOD JOB.
>> Juan: I AGREE WITH YOU.
THE DEEP STATE IS DOING A GREAT
JOB.
>> Jesse: I DIDN’T SAY THAT,
JUAN.
[LAUGHTER]
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PLAN IS.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
IS IT OPEN BORDERS?
IS IT TURNED THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM UPSIDE ON?
IF I HEAR A GOOD IDEA FROM THEM
THEM --
>> Greg: THAT WAS CONSTRUCTIVE